what's going on guys
so this week Hunger Games Catching Fire
is coming out and as we all know in a
dystopian future you're gonna have some
kind of reality show where people murder
each other today we're gonna talk about
that and we have super cool panel to
weigh in on that topic she is one of the
voices on the extremely funny podcast
the indoor kids it's emily v gordon hi
hello and he's a stand-up comedian and
just an adorable gentleman a stereoscope
no yeah let's be honest if Hunger Games
was an actual show on TV would you watch
it if I lived in The Hunger Games
universe I don't know that I would watch
The Hunger Games you would watch The
Hunger yeah you wouldn't know anything
else you would watch The Hunger it's for
the Republic you owe it to Panem to
watch yeah I don't want to see a bunch
of hipster mimes with blue hair put a
bunch of kids in a room and have them
kill each other let me tell you about a
show I would watch the Running Man a
show where a guy named Professor
sub-zero tries to murder people with a
sword hockey stick I'm glad you brought
up Running Man
because before Hunger Games there were
other dystopian futures where we watched
killing on TV
if you haven't seen it running man is
1987 Arnold Schwarzenegger where the guy
is at the height of his powers I live to
see you eat that contract but I hope you
live in a room for my fist because I'm
going to Ram it into your stomach and
break you Gotham's crime it is a reason
we have to have a running man in the
running and when the economy collapses
like society becomes district 9 or
elysium every time yeah for us it's it's
like the voice and Lowell Katz I think
are you those are our two methods look
if it wasn't for the voice I would be
running around in the street taking
people's heads off with a sword I
absolutely would here is Sub Zero now
plain zero another murder movie reality
TV show uh series seven real people in
real danger in a fight for their lives
on the contenders series seven is from
2001 and it's a really gritty kind of
like realistic date booth ten kills in
only two tours
she's been unstoppable now one month
before the birth of her child just five
lives stand between her and hope freedom
I prefer the ones that are like super
super flamboyant about it because stark
to me would probably end up being like
well this is a bummer yeah it's a total
bummer movie and is it still a comedy
though like what is it technically is it
an action it has very dark moments of
comedy so yeah a little too dark for you
wouldn't watch this show no I wouldn't
watch the show if it was on television
yeah I'm still sticking with my
teenagers need some very sexy teenagers
who might be or might not be in love
with each other
battling to the death ripped ABS rip
throat means everyone oh you know yeah
emilina studios let's shift gears and
talk about the film that Hunger Games
gets compared to more often than any
other movie battle royale a pretty
awesome flick am i right oh my god yes
absolutely this class of Japanese high
school students gets taken to an
undisclosed like island location
and they have to battle to the death The
Hunger Games takes an hour and six
minutes to get to the Hunger Games in
Battle Royale
18 minutes in you got a fat kid with a
crossbow shooting his friends Japanese
efficiency that's what I'm talking about
two kids are killed during the
explanation of the murder games they're
gonna be in Hunger Games often is
accused of some people say it's total
ripoff of these movies any thoughts on
this it's a story that we've been
telling for many many years and it's a
story we're gonna keep it we're gonna
keep having reality shows where people
have to kill each other
sue might as well find new ways to do it
every time so guys if you had to compete
in one of these futuristic terror games
which one would it be
I would definitely compete in the
running man I think you guys should too
because the thing is you only have to
face one opponent at a time in the
running man and they usually have a
super obvious weakness you can take a
nice break after you murder one of the
stalkers you know have some character
development with Maria Conchita Alonso
like The Hunger Games and Bell rail it's
just non-stop I need to catch five you
know yeah you don't want to catch fire
you want to catch five thank you em yeah
I think I would go I mean as much as I
like Hunger Games and I think that's a
lovely world and I feel like I could
probably talk some people out of doing
terrible things I could probably kill a
bunch of Japanese children I think it'd
be that hard cuz i'm you know much
larger than them and older so i'm gonna
go for the one where i survive which is
the one with the smallest children
gotcha
battle royale so which one of these
futuristic reality murder shows would
you want to compete in tell us why in
the comments section below best answer
gets a screen junkies t-shirt also next
week we're gonna be reading your
comments and answering your questions in
a special Thanksgiving episode leave
your comments and your questions below
and if we use it you also get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank my
awesome guests Emma levy Gordon the
indoor kids podcast a stereoscope knows
you could see his comedy all over the
place thanks again you guys thanks for
watching I'm how rednecks check me out
on Twitter bye-bye
what would either of you throw out there
as the worst remake ever Star Trek to
darken realities movie maker breathy
yeah there are some who will argue this
on a remake but it fits most of the
problems